president gave kind of a weird press
conference in an impromptu press
conference just a couple of hours ago
mm-hmm yeah President Trump said the
hate and the division must stop yes
that's what he said yeah yeah yeah for a
minute the crowd got excited because
they thought Trump was resigning now
this is I gotta say I didn't explain
need to explain this is we didn't see
this cuz this just happened Trump gave a
very president Trump gave mr. Protocol
he gave a very strange press conference
where he kind of undid whatever good he
did in yesterday's president yeah yeah
it's very strange and then some yeah and
then some yeah yeah said some very
strange things in his press conference
just a couple of hours ago President
Trump referred to the neo Nazis as
history buffs yeah yeah then he referred
to serial killers as population control
experts yeah so he's he's just renaming
things is all it was really strange
at his press conference you have to
check it out in the press conference
President Trump said that Steve Bannon
was a good friend and not a racist yeah
and then he said oops I meant to say a
good racist and not a friend
I just got it upside down
Google is stepping in Google has banned
the neo-nazi website the daily stormer
from its site for now so now if you want
to search for hate groups on the
internet you're completely out of luck
[Laughter]
that's funny because there's so many of
them so no we don't move that either I
just really technically wasn't even a
joke what I just did that was me just
saying something depressing yeah and
then just looking at you guys where's
all that whoo-whoo Conan Conan now no
you see my point we're in some serious
[ __ ] here in this yeah a is interesting
a little less intense a Florida man who
accidentally follow me on this
accidentally fired a gun in a strip club
restroom while trying to take a selfie
has been sent to prison yeah yeah the
weird thing is everyone else at the
Florida prison is there for the exact
same reason that's just what they do in
Florida
yeah it's pretty even picture how that
works might have had one of those new
gun comb yeah you know that they're
selling these days I've said some dumb
things in my time no no that was a guy
like that idea yeah yeah I would use a
gun go hey sex toy company and I are
leaning in a sex toy company is creating
a new product inspired by Game of
Thrones yeah yeah their motto is why
should winter be the only thing coming
[Applause]
you